[Music]
when i grow up
will i be able to grow a beard like that
you're a lasseter and lassiter men have
been growing legendary face wigs for
generations
it's a king's beard born in your blood
perfected through centuries
but never forget it's not the beard that
makes the king
i know i know it's the queen that's
right son excuse me
carlton i didn't realize you had
visitors
oh whoa whoa whoa sorry no pets pets i'm
sorry
oh that's morrissey he's a therapy dog
does he have a vest he does though he
prefers to call it a waistcoat
i think you'll find it all checks out
hmm
this is an ultheraflu t-shirt with tape
over the flu and py in sharpie
you're good one point for you dolores
how did either of you reach adulthood
don't worry you will too as long as you
keep taking your vitamins
okay i am not a child what do you want
isn't it obvious we want love and
companionship and the end of the ivory
trade but most importantly we want to
know what you think you're doing opening
a cafeteria in our office
well i am a legit entrepreneur and i
rented this space and it's mine for the
next 19 days oh those are for cats
see are you eating the patient's ice
chips
i am not he is that's not true we're
sorry we're just
we're both fans of delicious flavor
we're friends of the chief
carlton lassiter ah friends of the
chiefs hi
hello i'm dr herschel this is my
facility those
are my ice chips oh
you know i like will christina how you
doing we're new here
name's sean spencer this is my partner
lego my eggo
no norman brown butter try again sean
dijon hansu accepted why are you
rejecting nicknames in front of a
comatose guy because i'm a pro
penny for your thoughts vic save your
pennies dijon i got this
i see it jack daddy
you played straight huh tough guy from
the old neighborhood
probably didn't even cry when liz
berkley got addicted to speed and saved
by the bell
young lady i am dr americo cantalone
from the island country of cuba
reporting for work
dr catalone wonderful could you just
spell that for me
no no i cannot
[Music]
okay but
you look big it's slick sean gus what
are you guys doing in santa barbara
well i left a frisbee signed by a german
film director
florian henkel van danerschmark when i
moved and i've come back to collect it
gus has a new love interest down here
who happens to be a nurse that's not
true
can i have that it's evidence it's mine
you guys got here too quick for us to
fish it out of the ditch did you kill
that guy in the bus please the man was
dead before we spoke to him
what he died a second time buzz keep up
why are you here super top secret man i
can't tell you or anyone from your
department or any former members of your
department especially not
[Music]
jewels
[Music]
don't let anybody force you to do this
think about your child wait wait
wait you have a kid and you're willing
to go to jail
for nothing what the hell is wrong with
you how's this
nobody nobody i'm your best friend
best friend well you brought your best
friend with you you know what i'm done
you know what you're right we are done
you old dead beat deandre no look
face out what okay kessler wait we are
not done
you know what i may have overreacted
slightly
[Music]
i just wanted to look my wife in the eye
when i said let's go home
i love you so much
[Music]
you